real-time decision-making boot camp
today is the day of energy very pleased
to kick off the morning by two lectures
offered by Professor Steven o from
Caltech you'll be talking about solar
power thanks man and thank you for
coming so this is a boot camp and there
will be three pieces for hours for three
pieces I'll talk about the flow power to
bits up just basic concepts and basic
models and I will come back to that for
the motivation and then one of the
perhaps most important problems is which
is the power flow are the purple
solutions or popular optimizations and
the reason this is very important is
because last numerous power system
applications underline them are some
kind of powerful solutions or power flow
optimizations and all this is pasta
estate and Shawn then we will talk about
the dynamic models so the steady-state
behavior is suitable for behavior that
is of timescales
minutes and up and a lot of applications
are there and then their behavior in a
sub seconds or seconds timescale going
down to actually microseconds and so on
so Shawn will talk about the behavior of
the system and its timescales of seconds
up to a minute or so where for example
frequency control becomes very important
so he will talk about the control aspect
at that fast time scale and then
commercial we'll talk about the DeMarcus
so hopefully through that this program
will give an overview of really the
basics of power system from steady-state
to dynamics from engineering to
acknowledge all right so this is takes
instruction the level should be
sufficient Elementary so that people
experiment table you'll be poor so if in
power system you can safely skip itself
most part okay so the first part of
basic concepts models before I stop the
model the mathematical models let me try
to convince you why we should care but
power system watch we
kappa energy and then I'll talk about
three really key ideas are how do we
think about this gigantic system that we
built where there's all kinds of signal
that sinusoidal functions throughout the
network we want to balance them we want
to control them on the optimize them how
do we model this and then analyze it and
these for the steady-state behavior so
the three I think important concept that
allows us to deal with were simple
models eventually we use that model to
think about power flow optimizations and
then using those basic concepts became
model basic devices that lots of devices
that that boost its power system from
generators to transmission lines to
distribution lines eventually to Lowe's
and transformers regulators all kinds of
devices in the network and we'll focus
on mainly the transmission line which
perhaps is one is to give you a sense of
how do we model that but also this is
important in in terms of power flow step
then we interesting out a little bit
about transformers and and then not too
much about generators and then there's a
low models which is very complicated for
us it's just just one number or two
numbers that they represent alone okay
so without this devices model then we
can build a model for the network that
mathematically we can simply represent
it by a matrix called admittance matrix
so a lot of power flow optimizations is
expressed in terms of this admittance
matrix and then they're different forms
of power flow models they all describe
the same thing but if they have
different mathematical properties and
depending on the question till you ask
some for may be easier to analyze than
the other so we will talk about some of
the popular powerful models and then
maybe in the last build our formula was
called optimal power flow problem which
again is a fundamental problem in power
system simply because the underlies
numerous processes and applications and
then one and there are many
computational challenges in solving that
model optimizing the power flow within
that model and then I will talk about
one aspect which is combat realization
and then maybe the last 15 minutes will
be a little bit on the research which is
about real-time power okay
you have often powerful problems that
relates to the theme of this workshop
okay so that's the that's the plan why
smart grid so it really at a watershed
moment where if we look at the largest
magna carta fest perhaps the
communication network at least the
modern communication network is really
the telephone network and the AC
transmission power network both started
around the same time about 140 years ago
and both started in a very similar
engineering mark and rapid structure to
provide a single commodity extremely
Liability reliably so reliability is the
most important criteria in how we design
operate the network and both grew
rapidly through the true was post was
and both even started to directly around
the same time there is that is the era
where lots of the industry started to
deregulate and therefore the development
had been very parallel until about
twenty something years ago when the
telephone network took an architectural
transformation and converge to the IP
network because of this little
experiment that started in 69 so that
changes everything that the IMP is huge
it changes with plans we have multiple
industries the hope is that perhaps
there's also a architectural
transformation that is emerging that
will continue in the coming decades that
will transform the power system into a
much more sustainable much more dynamic
much more open and distributed form
perhaps becomes the most largest and
most complex IOT what will drive this
transformation so again in that
transformation if you look at what
happened with telecom the industries
have been restructured some of the
biggest companies didn't exist 20 plus
years ago the engineering structure has
been changed dramatically from a
centralized intelligent vertically
optimized to a distributed architecture
layer architecture that allows changes
beyond just communication just beyond
beyond just just engineering this is
dramatic changes and in fact there are
many factors that drive this but
Plus success of this transformation in
art in communication network if there's
one single element that is most
important it will be the layer
architecture the implication of this
layer architecture is it is really
profound so this is this these were the
largest companies by market cap ten
years ago and these are companies today
so it's a dramatic change so we will try
power network transformation
manufacturers and here are two if you
look at the economic sectors in the u.s.
that consumes of most energy all forms
of energy right so it is oil it's gas
it's called nuclear hydro hopefully
renewables is the electricity generation
and transportation so these two sectors
consume two third of all energies in
u.s. they also admit more than half of
greenhouse gases and therefore if we
really want to dress it reduce
greenhouse gases we have to electrify
transportation which increase the demand
for electricity and then we have to
generate electricity more and more from
renewable sources so that's going to
feel to really be I think the the
ultimate driving forces for power system
Neutron or energy system transformation
in the coming decades okay so looking
globally right so the world today or
2011 and seven years ago still mostly
the energy all forms of energy still
mostly depend on fossil the largest five
countries in terms of consumption try
the US Russia India Japan if you look at
per capita is different right and they
five largest countries consumed more
than half of all energy they also emit
the most greenhouse gas co2 emissions
but in half so if we zoom into the u.s.
it looks like this so we store this
before in the tree seat generation and
transportation generate more than half
of all greenhouse gases in u.s.
and they consumed 2/3 of energy if we
zoom into the energy so these are the
primary sources and these are the
applications and if you look at a treaty
generation so assuming to this the
picture looks like the following
so 2014 we generate slightly less than
2/3 of lectricity from fossil mostly
coal and gas very little oil right now
nuclear has been pretty steady at about
20% plus or minus and then renewables
that includes a hydro 90 more than 90
percent will a truth in the u.s. are
generated by about 10,000 large power
generators and there are lots of
distributors small generations but it
generates in terms of energy that or
capacity that they are much smaller and
therefore really this this generation
mostly are from espoused centralized
generators and just converting primary
sources to electricity we lose almost
2/3 so in order to raise to reduce this
dramatically we don't have to change the
architecture of how we general
electricity combined heat and power and
so are much more distributed for example
so eventually we use about 1/3 of the
primary sources
historically if you look at the supply
so the 15 is to it about today or so Co
has been grown steadily and tilled about
last ten plus years because it's shale
gas and gasoline increasing replacing
displacing coal
despite this past what we hear from okay
so if we zoom in so this is annual
numbers if you look at quarterly numbers
so that you see this red region see some
variation so gas has been catching up
with coal all those combines about 2/3
slightly decreasing nuclear is pretty
steady about 20% hydros by 8% into 10%
pretty second so winner solar is hard to
see software to zuni you so hydro is
about 8 to 10% so that's the reference
win has been catching up in fact the in
terms of capacity assert it has just
surpassed the the hydro capacity so that
that's a monster solar is still small
but it's rapidly increasing because the
price has been dropping and also because
new business models have been
popularized in the last five five plus
years okay so the hope of course is that
eventually this wind and solar you
displace most of hydro displace most of
the fossil so hydro capacity is about
saturated it's not a lot of extra hydro
capacity so this is by 2016 hydro
capacity has wind capacity has exceeded
hydro as a renewable so the interesting
thing for this is just this has been
several years in terms of neo capacity
installed Cohen 0 this is 2014 I in
terms of P the Renewable twin and solar
that's that's 75%
of new capacity so this is another
interesting chart that shows how rapidly
solar has been has been growing so these
are the forecast by IEA of the Solar
forecast from 2002 up to 2017 so every
year they have a forecast and these are
the actual trajectory so that's helpful
so some some one are other than some
calculations where they use the actual
energy consumption in 2008 and it make
assumptions to say what with the energy
consumptions by 2030 so that includes
all forms of energy and then asks if
we're just going to capture the solar
and then supply or their energy where
there's a lot of engineering that needs
to be happening you know to do it but
suppose we can do that then how much
area will be covered so that we can
supply all energy needs from solar so
this is supposed to to scale and not
sure how reasonable all those underlying
assumptions are but I think the point is
just way more renewable energy in nature
than we will ever need it's really up to
scientist engineers like yourself to
capture them to transmit it expedient
manager right which is difficult is this
an assumption that the entire
transportation is also elected by it
what is this just a very good question I
don't know I don't think so yeah
okay so so what are the challenges the
many challenges on the engineering side
one of them is this this uncertainty
that is the of the supply right so for
the last hundred years the way the
system was designed is that we have
complete control in supplying the demand
at least at the Abbadon level has been
pretty predictable and therefore the the
paradigm has been with forecast demand
and gives a very elaborate market
structure that allow us to forecast
increasing accurately as we as we
progress to a time of delivery so a
forecast demand and then we can schedule
supply so we can schedule exactly how
much generation power each generators
will suit generate when and where now if
we imagine 80% of our supplies are not
controllable not even very predictable
then drastic changes will be needed on
how we design operate the network and
also how we operate the market so this
is a a data from we found something kind
of us you South California anything I
see where this is the megawatts the
output power of the wind farm this is
time 24 hours the 30 Chris one per day
so we can see that the output fluctuates
randomly rapidly a large amount
so that's if we have this supply for 80%
of our and electricity generation
there's a problem so solar is the same
thing as clouds fly by the output can
drop by 80% within minutes in addition
we don't have solar at the night so
that's that's a challenge because of one
of the important challenges so this is
the measurement of the voltage at
function of time so the voltages in the
network every point in the network needs
to be gradually
tightly around certain nominal value so
here at the outer is a 120 vote in the
transmission different parts of the
network you have different levels so
here's a nominal voltage level every
point a network and that need to be
regulated tightly along there for all
kinds of reasons so this shows that
because of the solar penetration a
feeder on in Hawaii so this is time this
is voltage level and even parts of the
feeder and you can see that so these are
the law gives a nominal value this is
the upper bound low power you can see
that if the exist the the limits quite
often so the legal limits that you yes
so it's basically a line that brings
power from say substations somewhere in
the network to eventually to him so
we'll come back to this when is the
feeder is answer so it's basically part
of the power network that brings energy
think of it like transportation network
where the energy flows from eventually
from from from the generation of the
source true where we actually consume I
will try to minimize the the jargon okay
so and they will see this means
especially not only Hawaii Germany right
so these are these are real challenges
and because of all these challenges this
you create a lot of hardships economic
hardships and political challenges and
no they're okay but these are the things
we can solve if we have enough people
that work on this so hopefully it some
of the students will be motivated to
work on these problems okay so today's
grid we generate electricity so it's
about ten thousand about generators in
the u.s. that generate most of the
electricity so these are say coal gas
nuclear hydro hopefully solar farms and
wind farms
going through transmission network there
to a substation exam thing we just know
in a craft where where some of this
transmission lines terminate and then he
starts goes to another network was
called a distribution network eventually
to the households and commercial
buildings and all of them now the
difference between trans abstractly
mathematically transmission network
distribution they were the same this is
cloth physically fit a very different so
transmission networks are typically long
distance very high voltage so we see
later on why we need the voltage to be
so high so I think the highest voltage
now in deployments per in China a lot
about a medium vote right so this is one
point in the sky HVDC seen some of the
lines is 1 billion vote that mirtha
voltage the distribution networks are
shorter distance lower voltage but one
thing already we see that that different
voltage levels at different parts of the
network and and and that is important
and that is also one of the main reasons
underlying why about hundred years ago
we went from EC advocated by Edison to
AC have occurred by Tesla this check on
topology so this this is purely tree
tree like to Baja no point bags no loops
distribution network almost all of them
are tree light apology here are
exceptions San Cisco transmission
network they are almost always mesh
network with groups that actually has
the important computational implications
later on when we talk about opf towards
invariant
okay so many dumb lows so we don't
really control out that much at least
during normal operations anyone can turn
on the machine turn off your lights and
order them and therefore we let the low
do whatever they want we try to schedule
supply to meet the demand now one thing
that is very different between power
network and Internet is that there's
essentially no large-scale inexpensive
storage so supply demand must be
balanced at all times and they're all
points of the network so that is a huge
challenge and that's also why we need
these elaborate market structures that
the Commission I will talk about and
also why we cannot really separate
engineering form from economics in power
system okay so and therefore the control
paradigm has been as I mentioned earlier
that we forecast demand and then we
schedule supply to meet them I see has
been centralized huming the load you do
the worst-case deterministic so when you
choose the operating point you choose
one so that if any one of largest
generators or lines goes down there
never would still go to another
operating point that is safe now
question just to explain it right why do
you need to stay within a small band
tolerance in terms of voltage right
right so so the many answers but many
reasons but the short answer is that the
so I'll come back I'll come back to this
eventually what you need to design a
network for is that you have a forecast
on the lows so you need a certain amount
of power going to this part of network
and a certain voltage level so we need
this to be 120 volt a lot of the devices
are designed with 120 volt in mind for
example until for abstractly we forecast
where the lowest time what the voltages
they need and so on and then we can work
backward how do we what it you
we will be the voltage that we near the
generator set
now there's other factors that come into
play which is the in order to mean I
minimize the energy loss on a network we
need to transmit a verified voltage so
we will see later on why that is the
case and therefore the voltage level at
the the law which is specified by here
and the voltage level at a generation
they are not at a high level voltage
that we need so we need to step up so
there's where the transformer is
important to transmit at a certain high
level voltage so that we can decide the
whole system's accordingly
okay so but we'll come back to this
point so the future grief hopefully it
will look more like when we still have
last centralized power plants hopefully
we have more lot plans that are
renewable but also there are lots of
distributed generations
that much closer to the low rooftops
always and so on but also there there
there a lot of lows so if you think
about in the past we forecast low and
then schedules apply now the supplies
are not controllable much less
controllable then we really need to
explore if that's a bleat lean low to
control the consumption to manage the
supply in fact this can be done so Shawn
will tell you a lot about this say 70
percent of electricity consuming
buildings building has huge thermal mass
for example electric vehicle if we
convert electric vehicle Electrify
transportation so every electric vehicle
while depending on the size and that is
change and so on but roughly at least
today each need adds about one-third of
energy demand energy to a average
California household another power
demand may one to twenty times so if we
electrify transportation
when the one day is going to add to the
demand the stress student grid on the
other hand Eevee's are extremely
flexible laws and therefore we can
control those possible laws to try to
help integrate renewables and therefore
the the expectation is that there will
be a matter of distributed energy
resources that are intelligent that we
can control to help integrate renewables
so the control paradigm is not only
controlling those 10,000 large
generators right so in a pass or today's
network we control few large endpoints
and then there's maybe say a billion
endpoints that just downloads all they
do which is consumed in the future those
endpoints may be different they are not
just passive laws some of them may
generate some you will we measure we
communicate we compute in control and
therefore we have this huge network this
with energy resources and the control
plug that needs to be changed and if for
some applications it may be much more
distributed we need to close the loop
right this not it is no uncertainty you
can schedule everything as soon as we
have sufficient uncertainty we need to
close a loop it has we have we cannot
and will no longer be able do this
determine is the worst-case operation so
how do we think about Ritz I need to be
robust on all of them
so that that's the challenge so so it is
pose a risk in that all these distribute
energy resources they may introduce
frustrations in supply and demand in
frequency in voltage and so on but but
they are also intelligent that if we can
define the right control structure there
we can probably improve the robustness
security efficiency and so the an
example people like to use is is you
designed a fighter jet to be unstable
and then you wrap around so that you get
the performance they will wrap around a
active control to stabilize okay so
global energy demand will continue to
grow there's still more than a billion
people who do not have reliable
electricity there's more renewable
energy that we will ever need
so that's good news so someone will
figure out how to capture them there
will be connected intelligence
everywhere so the cause of storage
computing communication manufacturing
will continue to drop and therefore the
net waste
hopefully will become the largest and
most complex internal things and what
we're interested in I guess they did
this audience is to develop theories and
algorithms to help understand and enable
such such transformation that will
encompass it's just now it's not just
one discipline it's not only EE right so
every almost every day most of the
things that we are interested in this
audience will be will be required
control optimization stochastic data
economics and all that okay
so so that's hopefully some of you when
we convinced that we should care by
energy the rest of the the the bootcamp
really is just the basic power system so
so here's one motivation what I want to
do it so this never minded details so
we'll come back to this light later on
but the point is a lot of the power
system operations boils down to an
optimization problem that takes a form
like this right so and these this
describes the model of the network the
objective we want to minimize and all of
that so we can start with these this
mathematical model and just stuff and
just analyze it and deal with the
computational challenges and so on so
most part of this this just this just
this bootcamp really it's not about how
do we deal with this is it's about what
is this physical system that we are
dealing with and how do we model them
and eventually how do we come up with
this model and so most most an hour and
a half or so of the material really will
be what is underlying all this model
what what are all these symbols mean and
what are the assumptions and lying is
more
so so for mathematicians they just want
to start with this model that's
perfectly fine but the poor can do it is
about where this model comes back so
hopefully we get a sense of when we are
trying to deal with these computational
challenges how do they relate to the
physical system ok so that's what
so really the the the clever idea is by
Tesla its three-phase AC transmission
system and there are three key ideas I
think that allows us to develop the
model that we saw in a previous slide so
let me explain those three key ideas
before that let's try to visualize what
the greatest some pictures mostly from
from Sasha was there was a faculty
member here at Berkeley from student
happens to be ok so the gray is most
visible in the dark so he's a certified
picture of North America these are the
lines are underlying them about 190,000
miles of transmission lines so these are
transmission network high voltage and
about 70,000 miles of distribution lower
voltage dissipation networks so we saw
this before so they're different devices
and generators to substations and all of
them at different voltage levels so test
that's one important so so it looks like
this right so these are the generators
generated a certain voltage goes through
a transformer that changes the voltage
higher voltage goes to transmission
network so that the squares are breakers
you can even connect these connect open
close event to get to a sub transmission
network step down and then so clearly
higher voltage minimizes energy loss in
the network but high voltage just based
the device is much more expensive by the
installations and all of that it's also
that safe week that's why we
120-volt were low voltage here is safer
so he goes to the substations are
eventually get to the transformer
industry eventually come to the house
kill so what is it what does it look
like so this is an example of a
Keynesian plan and this is the this is a
service drop so that is line
distribution line eventually come to the
house and then go to a panel that your
panel in your house
and then the familiar panel you get your
licenses and hours this is the
transmission sub-station all those
machinery is that the transmission line
is huge towers if you drive down Highway
five you see some of that if you try to
run time you may see some from these
things substations again be a lot of
different devices and stuff abstractly
they they change voltage levels they do
more than that but often and then
eventually this is if you walk on your
street this is something that you might
see unless is underground and so
sometimes it's underground especially in
cities yes this little transformers will
go from say 12 kV or sometimes 9 kv to
120 or 240 depending on the lines that
come to your house so this is the
network right there that brings
electricity from generators eventually
down to where we consume what might be
the capital investment landscape I don't
really know much to have any intelligent
comment the only comment I have
interesting observation is that in the
last many decades there has been
consistent on the investment in
transmission capacity for the structural
reasons there there are economic reasons
there are political reasons why that is
the case but there's one interesting
conjecture I find interesting that also
my explain
it's an underlying reason which I just
find funny so if you look at different
countries the transmission that was
typically owned by one to maybe up to
four owners in the US I forgot a number
but hundreds and therefore per
transmission networks are probably good
if they are owned by many different
owners is hard to provision public good
so so I don't know how important this
reason underlies is under investment but
that's but the whole infrastructure the
u.s. power infrastructure is about a
trillion dollar assets so there's an
interesting proper question by that from
so Silas perspective we have this huge
infrastructure that depreciate and use
capacity decreases right and then you're
its new infrastructure that are
hopefully being peeled these are they
say the renewables or the smart grid
innovations and stuff so from a social
perspective what is the right investment
strategy for each one of them so that as
the all infrastructure starts to
depreciate and the capacity decreases
and then you have demand for cars in
north and you build up the new capacity
to try to meet the demand what is the
optimal sequence that that is that is
that is not clear but there's a
interesting point mod or that can answer
that question and then there are lots of
questions there were so another
interesting question in that thing is in
the transmission network the traditional
way this this investment is done in a
regulatory environment yet the new
infrastructure side or the PV is from
the roof and so on not solar fans power
utilities they they approach even by
market forces so can you design the
right incentive structure so that you
this surface agents can actually make
individual investment decisions that
turns out to be sauce reaction anyway so
we can discuss offline in terms of so so
let's started to look at its basic
models so the quality.we interests are
doing the voltages the currents and the
power energy is just indication of the
power all of those are sinusoidal
functions of time until display networks
and sinusoidal functions everywhere
ignore the parent supply and demand you
want to control them and so on how do
you according to them well we're
interested in steady state so the
sinusoidal function of time so first
time about it we take this one right so
here's the amplitude there's a frequency
nominal frequency of 6 is 3 Hertz here
and then there's a phase
so we're interested in this part of the
of the book hammer into the steady state
for us it means that the frequency is
the same at a nominal value everywhere
in the network therefore this function
is specified by just two numbers the
amplitude and the phase so this is
reasonable moderate time scales of
medicine up and again Strom will talk
about dynamic models for faster time
scales so this 5 is all about steady
state and therefore so given this is
fixed so these two parameters to specify
the signal and that motivates a was
called this motif phaser which is simply
given a voltage function sinusoidal
function you can form this contrast
number right so the limits and theta V
and so this phasor is related to that
through this simple expression so given
a voltage function you can write on the
phaser given a phase ii by county
so the next thing and also the the
magnitude of this complex number is to
Ruby the square of of the second
fragments so and therefore the first
concept interesting concept is that you
can represent voltage by its face
similarly for current given an
sinusoidal current you can write on its
face so what is useful so for example
the basic circuit element that's going
to model most of the power crease that
we will see right boys down to roughly
three circuit elements that we use so
the resistors the inductors and
capacitors and they follow laws of
physics so you have this voltage at the
time is the proportional to the changing
credit and so on yes so this is a time
domain so these are the brain circuit
elements to model the grid instead of
doing all your analysis in time domain
you can do all your analysis in the
phasor domain so just from the time
domain from a definite interface where
you can derive that there is a
relationship between the voltage phasor
in the current phaser across the
resistor similarly across the inductor
and the capacitor and therefore you can
do all your analysis in the phasor
domain when you get the result you can
translate back to the time domain which
is the physical system we care about so
so I have one example at some point on
how to do that
therefore phasor representation allow us
right so we can do a lot since high
domain or you face it away and this is
lot easier everything is going to be so
the steady state described by a set of
algebraic equations these are the power
flow equations that we'll come back to
later on so before before we can write
down powerful equations but when we
develop the models for the different
devices
eventually build up to the team the
power flow equations that describes a
network so again that's the point of
this book and where do the mathematical
models come from when we do is say okay
okay so that's a so so that's the
voltage and the current so if you're
interested only in voltage the current
denser linear system if but many say
loads and stuff are specified by how
much power we need eventually so evey
every kilowatt hour so f amount of
energy we can go say three miles
so we care about energy we care about
power and that is the product of the
voltage and current that's where the
non-linearity comes in so if the voltage
has this sinusoidal which is cosine
function current has a sinusoidal
function cosine function you do the
product it comes it becomes something
like this
so the interesting thing is that the
power is also sinusoidal with twice the
frequency so if you look at the average
power this goes away this defines the
average power so this motivates that we
can define complex power in terms of the
phasor so given a voltage across the
device given this current across that
this is the current Conchas conjugate
then we can define the product to be or
the contrast power the real part of it
is exactly this average power each time
time average and then the reactive power
is the emerging part of this the
imagined power has to do pass effect so
the real power typically depending on on
the type of law is what we consume say
charging battery we care about this but
reactive power in general does have
implications on how we design the
network operator Network which is of the
wire for example so the phasor analysis
that the steady state behavior described
by several super equations in terms of
face well in your face in phasor domain
power it's not a face so the voltages
and currents are linear but the power
flows are nonlinear so we are going to
describe all the devices and network
models and analyze them in phasor to me
knowing that once we get our result we
can always go back to to get the
physical quantity okay so so that's the
first idea the second idea is this free
face balanced operation okay so so
suppose we generate a Tracey somewhere
is it guess huge gas generator
eventually we bring to the low the low
consume certain energy so the current
flows through it and then returns it and
so on facts so these are three single
phase systems that brings power from the
generators to the low we can connect
them so that these three circles share
the same return path so you can connect
the generators right in the lows so they
share the same return path that six two
wires over long distance right we have
two hundred twenty sixty thousand miles
of these lines so that saves a lot and
in fact it turns out if we have a
balanced system which we define what it
is we can also save this wire so you
save half okay with this of the material
so so this this three-phase Tesla's idea
is really clever idea that you have
these three phase voltage source then
arranged like this it's called Y
configuration similarly Y all the
impedance all the noise like this or you
can have them connected wiring in
different way so this is Ho Delta
configuration you connect a to a p2p and
it will see it soon so the idea of a
balanced source balanced three-phase
source is that the devoted phases so
these are complex numbers faces at the
same magnitude and differ in phase by
120 degree so so the phase a voltage
source has some magnitude normalized to
one and some phase angle the phase B
version you subtract 120 and if I see
so it's a were specific arrangement of
your voltage physics right okay so it
turns out three phases have some
advantages we'll come back to that
so for face you have two faces four
faces you'll get some advantages but not
the others and so on
so three-phase and what is the
fundamental underlying reason for those
advantages and we'll see you see some of
that but phasor analysis is it sort of
physics patient it's kind of a very
degenerate form of frequency you can yes
you can think of yeah so we'll come back
to that
for example yeah
but we will come back to this some
advantages of a three-phase so that the
laws of balance impedance low so they've
given low models so for us mostly though
just impedance and we say their parents
if they are a technical just same
complex numbers okay so this is in the Y
configuration and then notice that the
voltage is between the face and the
neutral now in Delta configuration the
voltages are typically specified in
terms of the line to line so face a line
to face B line so they are balanced in a
Delta configuration if those voltage
across line a B add across a B across BC
and cross
CA and same magnitude if I want to
integrate this
and same thing if you are in the other
configuration identical thing it's
balanced refacing impedance look so
here's one example which we will come
back to later on but here's one example
where you have a three phase voltage in
Delta configuration you have a some
loads in two other configuration and
they in parallel you have some low in Y
configuration and then you can think of
this as the transmission line that goes
from the voltage source by the first
local more transmission line based wide
load three-phase light bulb in this
format there would be three filaments
oh you can't three light bulbs well you
have a motor which was to see then you
could have windings that supplied one
three-phase mode to keep three-phase all
the way through
if I understand your question yes it's
in our home we have very few of these
kinds of loads in typically no home
you only get one face I mean there can
be split face you so they're good to
forties and stuff but it's actually one
fix essentially unless will evey so we
have a we deploy evey charging system at
caltech those are three phases so we get
all the three phases and then you have
evey connected to save between phase a
be another unique natural phase B C and
so on and so you try to balance a little
bit on okay so the system we sleep the
balanced three-phase if the voted the
source is the voltage sources of a
balanced as defined previously the lows
are balanced and then the transmission
lines are identical so we'll come back
to transmission lines in much more
detail later on how do we model them
right so so this model transmission is
extremely simple model and there are
multiple assumptions how we care from
the piece of wire to to this model that
will go through each one but this is a
three-phase balanced system
okay so advantages right so there's
several in just one interesting thing if
you look at the one phase remember we
can have we can supply three lows by
three single-phase power right three
systems and each single-phase power is
this in time domain you face a domain
the three-phase is our single stream
phase would be the B phase a power plus
phase B plus phase C right so clearly is
three times the single-phase no surprise
the interesting thing is if you look at
the instantaneous power is simply the
sum of face a instantaneous power of
phase B and face sorry
VA VB VC okay so basically the
instantaneous power each face on the map
well it turns out to be a constant
so P is the average power of the single
phase or is a real part of this single
phase and therefore the instantaneous
part comes in time so if you supply the
three phase motor you can you can turn
smooth for example but also sort of
alluded to earlier if you use say the
three phase balanced operation versus
three single phase you save about half
of the material and lose about half of
the power during transmission I'm not
sure I understand what you mean by
average power in a single phase system
you have basically the root mean square
so it's root to the peak voltage is the
average voltage and in a three phase
system it's higher but I've forgotten
exactly so three-phase you simply you
get the same each phase if it's balanced
so one thing that we would actually talk
about leave your balanced operation the
phases decoupled so that each phase can
be analyzed separately and just like a
single phase thing and therefore the the
power in each phase would look like this
once they are balanced and decoupled and
that's the average power average simply
integral over the time average
okay so
okay so that's a second idea and the
third idea asked again Eric's question
of my three and going up two or four so
if you get poor for you are implying
that you won't get this okay one of them
you will you will not get at least I
forgot two or four and the other one I
forgot whether you care or not it's out
sixty so you get like sine squared theta
plus sine squared 90 minus theta so
what's what's the benefit of three base
versus one face I mean you kind of said
it but any quite understand well one you
said if it is balanced you can save the
return we turn while say that's like
half of the is that was six lines you
get three times
but when you can calculate the line loss
he's about to ruin an original idea when
he came up with three phases not to save
water assuming it was his supplier but
both are good reasons but historically
what was the reason they've led to Tesla
amending that and you don't know why
sweet because if you have one phase we
need three's one phase systems apply the
same amount power right and you boost a
lot more so you need more than three
three times three phase is mostly on
civilian power trades but three is not
like a magic number you can also go to
six or twelve if you want for example on
the ship or power systems most of them
are Chow phases but it's always it's
three plus three three times because
they give you these nice balanced
properties and you see the three phase
everywhere in the grid
in transmission network in distribution
networks that come to the houses
typically is a single phase again if
it's split face you get even powers but
given voltages levels but essentially
single phase to go to the house
okay so the third idea is we mentioned
that things simplify so that you don't
have to analyze all three phases so this
is one example of say a three phase
supply assume everything's balanced
supply to three phase lows in parallel
little B's I'll say the transmission
lines and so on then you can just do the
circuit analysis that all neutrals turns
out to be the same potential so neutral
to neutral voltage to zero and you all
boy sound eventually driven by that
devotees sources three-phase patterns
say many to give about 120 degree that
really underlies this these nice things
so so what are the implications one is
that you connect at least in the
analysis you can collect all the
neutrals there won't be current on there
so and also all the voltages and
currents line voltages currents
everywhere they will be three-phase and
parents and the phases that the couple
roughly means that the variables in each
phase they face a depends only on
quantities and face a but not on case B
or C so that allows us to - so these are
the properties there allows us to just
look at each phase and analyze it
separately so so if you look so you can
connect in your model you can connect
all the neutral lines then phase a is
just this this is a simple circle you
can analyze
so it turns out later on when we look at
transmission lines or transformers and
so on everything
has this nice prophase structure so they
eventually we just look at at least four
balanced three-phase system we just look
at single phase models the powerful
equations that we see usually in power
opf carbon for example they're all
single phase and that's the reason okay
okay so this is not a big cup of water
first so this is the case when
everything is in Y configuration they
actually didn't net is a neutral lines
and and everything it's done nicely into
this per phase equivalent circuit so for
a delta right there's no natural neutral
point but what you can do is that you
can convert a delta configurator
three-phase say source what is source
into equivalent Y configurations and you
curve that means they have the same
external behavior that is if you look at
the voltage say across MP here and a B
here is the same so if you work work
this out
then the equivalence is given by the
simple simple manner that if you if you
have a three phase voltage source in
Delta therefore we specify this EAP
between line a and B in Delta then the
corresponding neutral a phase voltage in
the corresponding equation y from
integration you simply that divided by
this compass number so it goes down by
square root of 3 and minus 30 degree
similarly for the other phases and
therefore we can convert a delta
configurator source to a y then okay we
can do the same thing for loan given any
low 3 phase load in Delta here's the
equivalent three-phase flow in one and
they have the same terminal behavior
that is if you apply the same voltage
say across a B and C
the current audience to AP and see you
be the same in two configuration so you
work this out then if I have a balanced
load in Delta then the corresponding
violent story why is just one fair of
them
therefore the professor analysis is that
given any circle right here some doubt
reduce my cover every Delta to Y and
then now you have a Y you can write down
the parfaits equivalent circles if it's
a do all your analysis then the
corresponding phase B and C variables
will just differ by 120 degree yes and
one can imagine that so the three phases
gun and then you know let's say my house
is hooked up to one phase my neighbors
houses of hook up hooked up to the other
phases now the loads may not be bad
that's right that's right
so in distribution system the balance
assumption is not a good assumption you
need to look at you really need to look
at unbalanced
so our touch one that is at some point
actually we way run out of time right so
we were to close this is from night of
your tens I did okay this I'm done with
this part it's one more minute right
then now if I interesting in variables
they like interior in detail for example
I'm interested in this current going
through this law right then you you need
to solve your regional circuit but now
you have a bunch of verbals already
figure from your from your perfect
analysis so let me just give you an
example not in detail but sketch what
what what this means okay so so let's
take this example so this is a delta
three-phase balanced source with the
line voltage between a and B to be this
year and times the drive factor so that
the preference source in Y configuration
just the again you can wear this to Y
converges to Y so this is
this would be wonderful sorry this we
weren't there okay so you convert this
to two to the Y you you get a y
configurated balance system this is a
corresponding per phase circle for face
eight circle for that Y configuration Y
system right so suppose I'm interesting
the time function v2 here and I one here
so the way you do this is that you
analyze this circle in the parfaits
circle so for me to the face so once we
get a v2 face that we can convert back
to the time function so that's this so
what about i1 well you can taste a
couple more steps but still simple from
from this circle you can solve for v1
which is the which is the voltage across
this so is the line to neutral voltage
phasor for the Y equivalent no so from
v1 you can calculate what is the the
voltage across this the line to line
voltage in the Delta in the face of me
so it gives is given v1 you can multiply
the right factor you get the line
voltage you ship at 120 degree here in
case you can figure out what is the
phasor voltage phasor cross a and C and
therefore you with not be the original
impedance you can figure out what is the
face of for the current from C to a once
you get the current phaser here then you
can figure I want it's just in terms of
current phaser - here's a direction so
that's the idea of the face with the
analysis okay I'm done
so so these are basic concepts and then
we can describe all the devices and
networks and analyze them you face it on
me and using per phase analysis so
that's the bottom line
after all this stuff we can just do for
phase analysis assuming it's balanced if
it's not then we cannot we have
- okay I will stop here thank you very
much so we will reconvene at 11 o'clock
this way